la mort de marcel carné 90 ans il a
signé quelques-uns des plus beaux
chef-d'oeuvre du cinéma français hôtel
du nord quai des brumes des enfants du
paradis
le hard rock café un des restaurants
branchés de paris accusé par les douanes
d'avoir servi de la viande d'importation
britannique interdites à la vente
zaïre le conflit tourne à l'affrontement
direct entre l'armée zaïroise et l'armée
rwandaise
madame monsieur bonsoir il est mort le
poète du cinéma français marcel carné 90
ans décédé ce matin dans une clinique de
clamart où il était hospitalisé
marcel carné c'est surtout le cinéma
d'avant guerre et des années 30 45
mais les plus jeunes qui le connaissent
moins n'auront aucun mal à reconnaître
quelques un des passages les plus
célèbres de ces films
symbole yeux tu sais
je vous assure chaque coup ça que vous
avez dit bizarre bizarre
moi j'ai dit bizarre comme c'est bizarre
marcel carné c'est une filmographie
éblouissante hôtel du nord on vient de
le voir quai des brumes les enfants du
paradis ou encore les tricheurs avec les
plus grands acteurs gabin michel morgant
arletty louis jouvet jean jacques dufour
évocation annonce 160 première carnet
avec les lettres de son nom on pouvait
aussi écrire le mot écran parti ce matin
il a sûrement rejoint les enfants du
paradis
quand j'étais malheureuse dormait je
rêvais mais les gens n'aiment pas qu'on
rêve alors il vous cogne dessus
histoire de vous réveiller un peu
heureusement j'avais le sommeil dur puis
dû reculer
l'image que je garde pour moi c'était un
homme avec un que
et c'était une caméra
caméra qui s'arrêtait
des choses innovantes
marcel carné petit homme rond au regard
pétillant de malice
malheureusement démodé par la nouvelle
vague laisse à ce qui reste un
formidable héritage journée rue entre 36
et 46 celui qui fut au début l'assistant
de rené clair et de jacques feyder n'a
tourné que des chefs-d'oeuvre des longs
métrages servi par des acteurs
exceptionnels des dialoguistes de génie
de prévert ou jenson est un merveilleux
décorateur alexandre trauner
alors ça c'est partout pareil que besoin
de changer l'atmosphère et moi
l'atmosphère cette fois c'est la
première fois qu'on prête à mot ce faire
je suis la mascarade rôle de relais à la
petite histoire du milieu 120 m a dit qu
est ce qu ils ont été emballés vider ma
faim prévert avait le génie de m une
poésie populaire sur le papier mes
carnets avait le génie de mettre cette
poésie populaire en images en noir et
blanc en plus
et alors les deux étaient
complémentaires et il était
indispensable l'un à l'autre les
atmosphères réaliste poétique c'est tout
cinéma de carnets qu'est ce que la basse
côte au gabon vous regardez votre
couteau et vous dites be there be there
non je croyais que moi j'ai dit bizarre
bizarre comme c'est étrange
pourquoi je dis bizarre bizarre je vous
assure cher cousin que vous avez dit
bizarre bizarre
moi j'ai dit bizarre comme c'est bizarre
finalement si je réfléchis bien c'est le
merveilleux d'une plaie plus c'est
merveilleux le romantique mon jeu très
romantique vous fonctionnez pas l'air
comme ça très sentimental club et wang
quan me voilà diaminar pas qu'il est en
pierre ou serait changée le merveilleux
le romantisme on le retrouve notamment
dans les visiteurs du soir même
transformés en statues les amoureux
continuent de s'aimer
galerie
si le coeur leur coeur continue de
battre celui de marcel carné aussi
puisqu'il est là sur l'écran à jamais et
ce soir après envoyé spécial france 2
diffusera en hommage à marcel carné le
film le jour se lève avec jean gabin en
vedette l'un des restaurants branchés de
la capitale
hard rock café menacée de fermeture
après que les services des douanes et
saisi 300 kilos de viande de boeuf en
provenance de grande bretagne est donc
interdite à la vente à l'exportation
depuis le début de la crise de la vache
folle cette viande congelée a été
découverte à l'occasion d'un contrôle de
routine des services vétérinaires
mathieu chez jean-michel nuire dans les
frigos des services vétérinaires de la
viande suspecte 300 kg de steaks hachés
congelés en provenance de la
grande-bretagne est découvert dans les
cuisines d'un restaurant parisien lors
d'un contrôle de routine une viande
strictement interdite en france depuis
l'arrêté du 21 mars 96 bris pour stopper
tout risque de transmission de la
maladie de la vache folle le hard rock
café un restaurant branché jusque trois
formes de sanctions
la première c'est là chez vous puisque
cette saisie est d'ores et déjà prononcé
la deuxième c'est une sanction dans
l'administratif la fermeture
d'établissements qui sera prononcé
prononcer si le préfet ange le juge
opportun
il sera prononcée par arrêté préfectoral
et la 3e troisième ordre de sanction
c'est la sanction pénale puisque il
s'agit d'une fraude et que cette fraude
est condamnée par le triple
au final actuellement le patron de
restaurant est encore entendu par la
police
selon lui la viande est d'origine
irlandaise elle aurait seulement
transiter par la grande bretagne pour
congélation pas de fermeture ce soir
mais l'établissement doit apporter la
preuve de la provenance de cette viande
déjà l'année dernière de hard rock café
avait été rappelée à l'ordre pour manque
de transparence dans l'origine de ces
produits et au luxembourg les ministres
européens de l'agriculture ont trouvé un
accord pour augmenter les indemnisations
versées aux éleveurs de bovins victimes
de cette crise de la vache folle la
france va toucher environ un quart de la
somme débloquée ce qui représentera
environ selon les régions entre 200 à
500 francs par tête de bétail
reportage dans une exploitation agricole
la région bordelaise françois privat
philippe ritter allez allez allez
il ya quelques mois de la retraite cet
éleveur est plutôt triste
installé depuis 40 ans dans le sud de la
gironde henri manceaux restent perplexes
al'annonce du déblocage de nouvelles
aides exceptionnelles de la communauté
européenne
les jets de gaulle actuellement à jouer
moi c'est un peu de beurre et une
tartine de pain sait très peu de choses
c'est nîmes parce que ce n'est pas avec
ces salles france une vache ou par
l'ajout ou de sega devrait pas
contribuer mais qu'est ce qu'on lit que
ça soit pour relever un pauvre paysan
dia qui a vu qu'a eu quelques passes
trop freiner et dit ne peut pas survivre
à ces fermes arabe et chaque année au
mois de février
les éleveurs se rendent à bazas au bourg
pour fêter traditionnellement le
broutard ici la bazadaise comme on
l'appelle produite une viande de qualité
après la crise de la vache folle son
prix a chuté de 40% des limousines de
très bonne qualité motors se vendait
jusqu'à 6000 ont le ventre remis le 5
et encore on n'a pas pris
aujourd'hui henri pense surtout à
l'avenir des jeunes éleveurs au moment
où les cours frémissent quelque peu
d'ailleurs petit à petit maintenant on
s'aperçoit que d'aller voir la qualité
ça ça reprend du poil de la bête à quoi
je parlais mais on a quand même recette
dinan sur quelques bons la carcasse de
francs contre 52 kg et les bouchers
boguey ils ont vu que la clientèle
ordonné les aides communautaires seront
débloqués rapidement et dans quelques
semaines les éleveurs du bazadais
toucheront les premières primes
exceptionnelles un avion brésilien s'est
écrasé aujourd'hui au décollage à
l'aéroport de l'aéroport de sao paulo au
brésil l'appareil un fokker avec 95
passagers à bord s'est écrasé sur un
quartier de la ville faisant d'autres
victimes bertrand on dirait la guerre
c'est une rue d'une banlieue de sao
paulo quelques minutes après le crash
d'un fokker 100 de la compagnie
brésilienne tam
dans sa chute l'appareil a démoli un
immeuble est pas moins de huit maisons
avant de s'embraser et de disperser ces
débris sur plusieurs centaines de mètres
l'avion qui reliait sao paulo à rio de
janeiro s'est écrasé ce matin pour une
raison encore inconnue peu après son
décollage sur un quartier populeux qui
s'étend jusqu'aux pistes de l'aéroport
les 95 personnes qui étaient à bord
89 passagers et six membres d'équipage
aucune n'a survécu
dans les minutes qui suivent l accident
les pompiers regrouper les corps à même
le trottoir dans des sacs en plastique
des habitants du quartier figure sans
doute au nombre des victimes dont le
bilan reste à établir un détail intrigue
les enquêteurs c'est un gros paquets de
cocaïne découverts parmi les débris de
l'appareil au zaïre alors que les
nations unies l'europe cherche toujours
à réunir une conférence internationale
pour tenter de mettre fin à la
catastrophe humanitaire
des combats ont eu lieu autour de la
ville zaïroise de goma à l'est du pays à
la frontière avec le rwanda combats
entre l'armée zaïroise et les rebelles
tutsis pour la possession de l'aéroport
sur place nous envoyés spéciaux martine
laroche-joubert michel levasseur
l'aéroport de goma l'armée zaïroise nous
emmener ici pour nous montrer qu'elles
contrôlent toujours les lieux malgré les
attaques menées la nuit dernière et ce
matin par des unités venues du rwanda
notre présence par des tirs de mortiers
et de mitrailleuses lourdes menaces et
la colonie couvrait à ma gauche la lave
et un peloton qui te venu tenter un peu
attaquées et la peau et ils ont trouvé
une force c'est là une sorte de fond de
la mine heureuse qu'ils avaient poussés
ils ont osé de venir vous attaquer mais
ils sont tous éliminés sur tous éliminés
choqués et nous a totalement aussi
viennent nous serons prêts l'aéroport
est donc toujours aux mains des forces
aériennes malgré les tirs d'artillerie
et les incursions d'éléments venus du
rwanda
difficile pourtant de prévoir ce qui
peut se passer ici face à l'urgence ce
général vient d'être nommé gouverneur de
région
il cumule tous les pouvoirs ce quoi que
nous sommes derrière comme l'avait
déclaré noter c'est en général
des échanges de coups c'est quoi déjà
c'est une guerre
une patrouille de nuit dans les rues de
goma après le couvre-feu de six heures
du soir
on entend quelques tirs d'artillerie et
d'armes automatiques
l'armée zaïroise ici est un état d'
alerte maximum
confirmant ce que l'on vient d'entendre
selon le ministre des affaires
étrangères français monsieur hervé de
charette
il est clair que l'armée rwandaise vient
en aide directement aux rebelles tutsis
du zaïre et puis enfin ce soir la croix
rouge qui restait seul sur place dans le
camp de réfugiés de goma a décidé
d'évacuer son personnel en france 45
mille ménages menacés d'expulsion attend
demain 1er novembre la trêve hivernale
qui durera jusqu'au 15 mars prochain
pendant cette période personne ne peut
plus être expulsé de son logement c'est
la loi cette année est marquée par une
progression sensible des cas d'impayés
qui met en difficulté les locataires
mais aussi les propriétaires qu'ils
peuvent toucher leur loyer pascal nous
c'est bon frédéric porte pour elle la
trêve arrive juste à temps
jacqueline a épuisé tous les recours dès
mars prochain elle et son fils de 14 ans
seront expulsables aux visiteurs elle
montre volontiers la dégradation de son
deux pièces
le propriétaire n'entretient plus parce
que jacqueline ne paie plus depuis deux
ans après le décès de son mari elle à
3000 francs pour vivre pour 3800 francs
de loyer
jacqueline attend des propositions de
relogement mais si les assistantes
sociales ne trouve rien ce sera la rue
et bien franchement si je suis pressé je
sais que mon fils a peut-être paix dans
la famille par les enfants mahjoubi
franchement j'aurais tellement au dessus
ne fêterait holler bien sûr les ennuis
de marie france sont sans commune mesure
mais elle s'en serait volontiers passé
le locataire de son studio n'a pas payé
pendant plusieurs mois avant de
disparaître
marie-france règle encore un crédit
chaque mois sur le studio en question
résultat 70 millions de pertes sèches et
on est peut-être passé d'un cas de
figure où les locataires avait vraiment
très peu 3 ce qui est préposé
effectivement d'autres problèmes que je
connais beaucoup moins bien et je pense
que maintenant on est quand même arrivé
à une situation où finalement s'ils sont
un peu adroits ils arrivent à ne pas
payer pendant une durée une période
extrêmement longue
la demande pour ce qui serait de
locataires solvables aujourd'hui aider
je mens pourvu est en réalité le
problème c'est que on a tellement de
gens qui ont des difficultés à se loger
et qui ont des revenus modestes qui vont
se tourner vers ce locatif privé que bon
bout de quelques mois ou quelques années
en europe et au moyen de payer toucher
aussi les organismes hlm mais eux sont
indemnisés dans certains cas cela coûte
250 millions de francs par an à l'état
sans pour autant couvrir tous les
impayés loin de là pas de quoi inciter à
accueillir les plus démunis jacqueline
n'a jamais eu de propositions de chaînes
le chômage a de nouveau augmenté en
france au mois de septembre +0 9% 27000
personnes ce qui porte à 3 millions 112
milles 800 le nombre de sans emploi dans
notre pays soit 12,6 pour cent de la
population et à propos de chômage
récemment la cour des comptes a critiqué
la manière dont une des dispositions
anti chômage des comptes pleura les
contrats pardon emploi-solidarité 700
mille en france et est utilisé dans la
mesure où il ne débouchait pas sur des
emplois permanents a contrario l'exemple
qui va suivre montre comment ces crs
peuvent permettre une véritable
insertion des jeunes il s'agit de
casques verts employés à nettoyer les
digues de camargue patrice velay peau de
sica des contrats emploi solidarité ces
e s il y en a plus de 60 aujourd'hui sur
les digues de camargue
tous ont connu le chômage ou les petits
boulots ici il retrouve une raison de
travail et des habitudes aussi pour 2600
francs nets par mois
les casques verts leur propose un
tremplin vers la réinsertion
je pense qu'il fallait que je fasse mes
preuves en faisant un contre ces risques
mais comme on était on est bien entouré
par un chef de l'équipe qui a pas de
problème france mais elles vivent dans
l'ambiance et ça vous a donné envie de
retravailler vraiment auraient tout à
fait ils sont plus prêts pour aller
travailler dans les entreprises normales
pour une raison simple c'est qu'ils ont
été préalablement formés chez nous et
qui partent avec un véritable bagage une
formation c'est une chance
supplémentaire environ 75 que verts ont
trouvé un véritable emploi depuis deux
ans soit la moitié des 16 es de
l'association comme jean-paul il encadre
aujourd'hui des jeunes en difficulté
pour un salaire mensuel de 7000 francs
brut environ
leur objectif commun rénover un centre
équestre dans
région d'arles des essais j'ai motivé
leurs enfants de passer le kärcher j'ai
de la pâture des broussailles et des
digues de camargue
à la décharge de marseille athmane lui
aussi est maintenant en contrat à durée
indéterminée après un an de crs à 34 ans
il gagne le smic et travaille à 5 heures
du matin mais ne fait pas le difficile
chemin avec 2200 francs que j'ai touché
au chômage je pourrais pas vivre avec ma
famille possible maintenant
mais ces exemples sont rares un slot sd
bouge trop peu souvent sur un véritable
emploi une vraie réinsertion au
ministère du travail
aucune statistique n'existe alors que
ces contrats date de 1989
on fait souvent la comparaison entre la
régie dit et de la lys lation sur
l'emploi en europe et notamment en
france par rapport aux états unis à une
semaine des élections présidentielles
américaines
la comparaison vaut la peine d'être fait
en quatre ans de présidence bill clinton
a créé plus de 10 millions d'emplois
mais pour une bonne partie il s'agit de
petits boulots et par ailleurs les
américains ont l'habitude de traverser
leur pays pour trouver un travail au
salaire du marché c'est notre enquête de
ce soir menée par notre envoyé spécial
qui a étudié et intitulé les nomades de
l'emploi la route 85 d'atlanta la
virginie elle traverse tous les états du
sud plus qu'ailleurs on y croise ces
derniers temps de curieux cortège
des maisons entières qui suivent leurs
propriétaires dans leurs déménagements
beaucoup d'américains vient ainsi du
nord où les industries moins
compétitives ferment leurs portes
bruno est un de ceux là
il y a quelques mois et il est licencié
son usine dans la région de washington
est délocalisée au texas
là bas il n'y a pas de syndicat et les
salaires sont plus bas
bruno trouvent du travail en caroline du
sud à plus de mille kilomètres de son
domicile
les alertes des techniciens sont plus
bas dans le sud que dans le nord mais
ils ont augmenté ces dernières années
pour atteindre actifs et qu'en laissant
les syndicats des conditions qui attire
les entreprises fabricant de pare-chocs
lusine de bruno elle est française a
suivi son client un constructeur
automobile allemand qui s'est installée
ici il y a deux ans le patron de bruno a
embauché trois cent cinquante personnes
en quelques mois une embauche facilitée
par l'état qui contre toute idée reçue
est actif aux états unis il faut pas
croire qu aux etats-unis n'y a pas des
aides pour les entreprises c'est à peu
près du même ordre que ceux qui lisent
que ce qui existe en europe
c'est simplement très facile d'accès les
dossiers sont très simples les légendes
de l'état que vous avez en face de vous
sont là pour répondre pour faire le
travail et pour faire le travail au
moindre coût
en quelques années le visage de la
caroline du sud a radicalement changé
longtemps rurale et pauvre frappé dans
les années 60 par la crise du textile la
région c'est d'abord diversifié puis
développé l'essentiel des emplois a été
créée grâce à l'industrie les travaux
publics autour de chaque usine tous les
services ont trouvé leur clientèle des
hôtels des restaurants se sont
construits
la plupart recrutés par voie d'affichés
du personnel que l' agence pour l'emploi
peine à trouver mais le métro nord-est
la flexibilité c'est le revers de la
médaille les emplois qualifiés ou pas ne
sont pas stables
licencié de nous pouvait le faire il n'y
a pas de restriction qui vous en empêche
mais fo prône aussi des affaires
marchent l'ordre ailleurs voudra libre
de licencier les employeurs fixe aussi
les salaires sans autre contrainte que
le marché ils sont souvent insuffisants
alors beaucoup d'américains cumule deux
emplois en période de croissance quand
l'emploi est abondant la plupart des
américains ils trouvent leur compte
mais en cas de crise la chute peut être
brutal il faudra repartir
c'est le prix à payer pour rester dans
la course
en france l'assemblée nationale a adopté
ce soir pour la première fois la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
l'ensemble de la majorité
udf rpr a voté ce jour même le président
de la république a reçu à déjeuner les
membres de la direction du groupe udf de
l'assemblée nationale à l'exception
remarquée du président de l'udf françois
léotard qui dimanche dernier avait
appelé le chef de l'état a remanié son
gouvernement
la jupe est au plus bas dans les
sondages selon la sofres pour le figaro
magazine en octobre sa cote de confiance
est de 23 % - 4 par rapport au mois
précédent et le président la république
32% de cote de confiance cinq points de
moins
les suites de la sphère charles hernu
hier soir dans notre journal un ancien
espion roumain confirmait que charles
hernu avait bien été correspondant des
services secrets roumains à paris jusque
dans les années 70 aujourd'hui à sofia
un ancien diplomate bulgare cité dans l'
enquête du magazine l'express dément
tout rapport avec l'ancien ministre
socialiste
enfin aujourd'hui à moscou est la femme
d'un diplomate présenté comme un agent
du kgb à paris dans les années 50 dément
elle aussi toute relation d'espionnage
avec charles hernu dominique derda eric
misse propre galina il recueillera se
souvient de charles hernu le nom lui est
familier le visage un peu moins les
années 50 c'est bien loin
à cette époque elle et son mari était
diplomate à l'ambassade celui ci
remarque diplomate jure-t-elle rien de
plus et surtout pas espion
comme l'écrit l'express en grosses
lettres ce conseiller d'ambassade de lui
arracher sa part identifié comme
vladimir ivanovic et l'ofev est une
grande pointure de l'espionnage
soviétique
le rire comme démentie à paris vladimir
you pay est fut d'abord conseiller
culturel puis chargé de suivre la
politique française c'était son premier
poste à l'étranger auparavant il avait
travaillé avec staline et molotov à jose
enduit de 76 ans il souffre de problèmes
cardiaques admis en début de semaine à
l'hôpital du kremlin il demeure
invisible mais il tient à réagir à ces
accusations par la voix de son épouse et
votre mari se souvient charles diagne il
a dit oui il a dit qu'il est un
dirigeant des désorganisations socialise
c'était les rapports proche entre votre
mari est charlie non mais des combats
avec les autres beaucoup de contacts
avec les vous ignorez tout des activités
du du kgb à paris à l'époque sont des
choses dont même aujourd'hui on ne parle
pas ou en 1955 deux ans après la mort de
staline la consigne donnée aux
diplomates soviétiques en poste à paris
et est de tout faire pour dégeler les
relations entre l'est et l'ouest
il fallait multiplier les contacts l'a
dit me régale i know you pay est qu'ils
sont employés avec toute l'ardeur
nécessaires comme le font aujourd'hui
encore parce que c'est la base de leur
travail
les diplomates et les espions jacques
chirac le président en appliquant
personnes s'inquiètent du passage de la
monnaie française à l'euro à partir de
la fin de ce siècle il a demandé qu'on
invente donc un gadget afin de faciliter
les conversions et éviter que les
français du mal à passer d'une monnaie à
une autre comme ce fut le cas souvenez
vous pour les nouveaux fronts il ya 36
ans de cela
luc d'asie claude sicard je comprends
bien oui bah vous irez faire les calculs
à ce régime là
hier beaucoup du bon s'ils perdent aux
habitudes de vie sera diffusé demain sur
les avantages qu'ils puissent y avoir de
nombreux morts ça j'ai pas encore fait
le calcul mais enfin ça pour moi dans
l'histoire ça c'était il ya un peu plus
de 36 ans quand il fallait passer des
anciens aux nouveaux francs aujourd'hui
les réactions ont peu changé quand on
parle du passage du franc à l'euro
moi je sais pas pour moi c'est
totalement inconnu parce que je me suis
absolument pas penché dessus
une seule virgule sera pas tes mélange
pas s'affoler calcul si l'on est à
mesure je pense pour tombe d'ailleurs on
est toujours mais c'est hors il a eu du
changement mais je crois qu a pas
d'autre solution là les francs devraient
avoir définitivement disparu dès le 1er
juillet 2002 alors pour simplifier les
calculs monsieur et madame ça l'état ont
imaginé un système électronique de
conversion frappé surpris f vous l'avez
en francs mais vous l'avez un euro c'est
mon épouse qui est vide et elle m'en a
parlé j'ai fait alors subi excellente
idée
quelques instants après le dîner j'ai
même trouvé le nom un nom déposé
aujourd'hui par ses inventeurs avant que
d'autres ne se lance dans la bataille
des gadgets
le père de la carte à puce lui imagine
déjà un objet de la même taille qu'une
carte de crédit
capable de convertir les francs en euros
et réciproquement chacun réinvente la
calculette il ya dix boutons au moins à
prévoir et donc ça ne se fera pas avoir
la taille de
une prochaine d'allumettes faut qu'il va
naître en courant le format de carte de
crédit et d'un format très connue très
homologué très accepté donc voilà ça va
dans le sens d'une cave du pays le
président de la république a suggéré de
penser à un objet aussi indispensable
que le porte-clés multiplication ou
division chacun pourra alors parler la
même langue
aujourd'hui encore même si nous n'y
comprenons rien ou presque rien nous
sommes familiarisés avec les puces
électroniques qui se trouvent partout
des cartes de téléphone ou de crédit en
passant par les ordinateurs et pourtant
les microprocesseurs c'est le nom savant
des puces donc 25 ans d'âge mais en 25
ans elles ont subi un sacré régime
amaigrissant remet albanie dans les
années 50 on les surnommait usine à gaz
de curieuses machines bruyantes
clignotantes et surtout très encombrant
des monstres aux capacités logiques
pourtant ridicule quelques dizaines de
calcul alors seulement pour celui ci on
n'est pas qu'un véritable miracle
technologique avec bénédiction papale
s'il vous plaît
quarante ans plus tard ce petit carré
doré pas plus grand qu'un ongle la puce
réalise chaque seconde le travail de
cinq cent mille ordinateurs d'autrefois
une invention née il y à 25 ans tout
juste dans la tête de ses ingénieurs
californie
on a utilisé un petit ordinateur mais
programmé pour réaliser des opérations
multiples aujourd'hui les puces sont
partout 10 milliards de micro
processeurs sur la planète
elles permettent même des innovations
stupéfiante par exemple c'est ingénieurs
travaillent avec un collègue basé à
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres via
l'ordinateur tous les deux se voient se
parlent
grâce à la puce
ils peuvent simultanément travailler sur
un même document
comme s'il était l'un à côté de l'autre
et capables d'en viron exécuté 120
millions d'instructions
petit à petit la puce est entré dans
notre vie quotidienne
c'est elle qui calcule dans les jeux
vidéo les cafetières programmables ou
les radios de ligue et bientôt plus
personne au volant des voitures ou
plutôt si des puces qui conduiront nos
automobiles intelligent nos est sans
aucun doute le bien le plus précieux du
continent africain est un projet de
barrage en namibie située au sud ouest
du continent africain risque d'assécher
le delta du fleuve au kawenga une
immense réserve naturelle déjà touchés
par la sécheresse depuis plusieurs
années qui pourrait bien rapidement se
transformer en véritables déserts
valérie gâcher le delta d'okavango qui
s'étale sur près de 15 me kilomètres
carrés est l'un des derniers paradis
terrestre au coeur du botswana cet
immense labyrinthe aquatique abrite des
milliers d'espèces végétales et animales
c'est un trésor régionales mais d'une
importance internationale
c'est un écosystème précieux sa valeur
va être de plus en plus apprécié
d'autant que par le monde un tel milieu
vient mariage mais un dangers menacent
le delta
la sécheresse qui sévit depuis trois ans
dans tout le sud de l'afrique
la namibie envisage de construire dès
l'an prochain un pipeline pour puiser de
l'eau dans le fleuve okavango qui trace
sa frontière nord avec l'angola pour les
habitants du botswana
ce projet ces figures de catastrophe car
une réduction même minime du débit du
fleuve pourrait assécher des zones
entières du delta d'okavango qui se
trouvent sur leur territoire des zones
qui serait alors avalé par le désert du
kalahari vous à vélo vous avez les
animaux qui viennent s'abreuver need you
vous avez aussi les autres danger pour
la vie du delta l'apparition au botswana
d'une pneumonie bovine elle a poussé les
autorités à ériger ces barrières qui
couvre déjà des centaines de kilomètres
il est même question d'en construire
d'autres plus au nord
ces barbelés ont gravement contrarier
les migrations d'animaux sauvages ces
girafes lions par exemple pas survécu
les défenseurs de la nature demande
aujourd'hui qu'on aménage des corridors
pour que les troupeaux puissent se
déplacer librement d'un pays à l'autre
comme ils l'ont toujours fait le sport
avec le tournoi de tennis de bercy cet
après-midi hedberg a battu lors des
vibert et le et marc rosset le suisse à
triompher de l'espagnol montpetit ya en
ce moment
le dernier joueur français en
compétition arnaud boetsch affronte
l'américain michael chang loi si en
direct il a gagné le premier set beach 6
5 c'est bon signe
il vient d'entamer le sou le deuxième
set on en est à 2 jeux à 1
pour botch dans ce match
le tournoi de bercy encore à vue
vous en souvenez sans doute les
principales têtes de série tomber comme
des mouches dès les premiers tours
sampras agassi becker et d'autre il faut
dire que ce tournoi pourtant richement
dotée arrive très tard dans la saison et
les joueurs sont carrément épuisé
françois brabant didier ranker garder sa
tête de série bien accrochés sur les
épaules c'est pas toujours facile
d'abord il y avait peut-être trop plein
celle de pete sampras semblait bien la
sienne
le numéro un mondial était en finale à
stuttgart dimanche dernier une finale
longue 3h30 5,7 et les meilleurs joueurs
du monde vont souvent au final alors
rejouer tout de suite contre euro sais
c'est dur en ce qu ils se répondent que
les joueurs une semaine de repos entre
les deux je pense également que le
système des garanties de tavaux 48 qui
permet aux cette fête le ferry d'être
exempté du premier tour est une erreur
et au lieu de protéger cette gc risque
était but de l'opération
en fait les contraint à jouer d'autres
joueurs qui ont déjà joué un match dans
les conditions du tournoi et c'est en
général peuvent les surprendre ensuite
il ya les têtes valent fait mal fichu
momentanément courrier relève de
blessure krajicek est carrément tombé
malade en plein match
nausées maux de ventre le vainqueur du
dernier wimbledon a quand même essayé
histoire de ne pas perdre trop de points
au classement mondial et puis il ya les
tête près du bonnet celle qui dans les
mauvais jours en et explose c'est vrai
que public de bercy peut être turbulent
mais pour becker hier les spectateurs
étaient carrément un enterrement et pas
de stuttgart calme tranquille à un asile
de fous mais c'était comme ça déjà les
années précédentes
oui et quand je chantais du tournoi je
t'ai bon pour un séjour en maison de
repos et encore j'ai joué contre un
espagnol imaginez si j'avais dû jouer un
français vous reviendrez jouer ici il
faut que je demande à ma famille à mon
fils il m'autorise à revenir aux au
moins littéraire mais tout aussi direct
cédric pioline aussi
s'est plaint de l'attitude du public de
bercy bref pour les têtes de série il y
a plein de bonnes raisons de perdre la
tête de temps en temps certaines
pourtant sont plus difficiles à faire
tomber que d'autres arnaud boetsch ce
soir de trouver la méthode pour
décrocher celle là le football
maintenant match retour de la coupe des
coupes européennes nice nous pardon
sévèrement battus à l'aller 3 1 qui
n'avait plus aucune chance de se
qualifier à gagner tout de même pour
l'honneur cet après-midi face aux
suédois de zone a10
me voici celui au théâtre mogador à
paris pour une quinzaine de jours les
harlem gospel ces chanteurs noirs font
revivre la grande tradition de la
musique et du chant noirs du sud des
états unis au brier de l'ère bernard
puis ce sont les noirs américains
mettent leurs rêves en musique cela
s'appelle le cos père chante année grèce
et de ferveur religieuse
il exprime la résistance à l'injustice
du travail oblige et dans les champs de
coton jusqu'aux émeutes contre la
ségrégation dans les années 60 le gospel
est resté un hymne de d'espoir
c'est cette histoire-là de l'amérique
que les chanteurs du harlem gospel
viennent raconter à paris avec queen
esther marrow elle a débuté avec duke
ellington
elle a chanté dans des galas de charité
organisé par martin luther king
je n'oublierai jamais ma tournée avec
martin luther king ça va laisser un
souvenir indélébile est grave parce que
j'ai réalisé alors que même si je
n'étais qu'un singe individus je devais
essayer d'améliorer autant que je le
pouvais elle court le monde autour de
moi maintenant je vais vous demander un
petit cadeau pourriez-vous nous chances
et quelques notes de machines grèce
mais
ise
si les jeunes préfèrent toujours mis le
rap queen esther saura vous rappeler que
sa musique engendré le blues le jazz et
le rock and roll
voilà c'est au théâtre mogador à paris
dans un instant la météo sophie davant
point route patrice drevet ce soir
envoyé spécial avec le portrait de
madame chirac à ne pas manquer ensuite
en hommage à marcel carné le film le
jour se lève avec jean gabin demain à
13h vous retrouverez patrick chêne et
demain soir à 20 heures ici même bruno
masure je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bonsoir